[Music]
the year
is 20
50.
you new yorkers
you're shoveling snow from halloween to
easter
and californians
you love skiing
your season is cut in half
and don't think about running up to
canada or montana just yet because those
wildfires are right on your feet
some of you
are just over the age of 60.
and you can't help but wonder
what on earth happened in the last 28
years
well
here's what happened
you finished school
transformed into the entrepreneur of
your wildest dreams
half of you married just above your
league
the other half just under
some of you may have reproduced
stacked a few companies
and you manage a 20 billion dollar
business
okay
but what else have you bore witness to
wheat
gas and latte prices that have tripled
since the russia ukraine attack of 2022
your neighbors
half of whom are migrants
who have come because their counties
are too hot flooded or fragile
let that sink in
your oldest is finally going to college
what a relief
and your youngest well both of them
never got to enjoy sports in the same
way that you did
because they're also wearing masks half
the year
not because of covet but bad air quality
you're forced to reckon with yourself
are my unbridled successes
worth what i have left to my children
this look into the future
our future
is not meant to paralyze or
instill fear no because it's not written
in stone
for the next 30 years if there's one
thing you ask of me
that can shift
the narrative on climate change
it is not these three things
put all your money in one stock
put all your money in one job
or a magic bullet through a non-profit
or an investment
instead what i tell you today
is that where your behavior will matter
most for the next 30 years
is in your hands in the form of the vote
and civic engagement
civic
engagement
underrated free
necessary
and undertapped
by the business community and all of us
before i go on i want to confess that i
came to business school yes business
school for the same reason as most of
you
to take outsized bets on my career
i want to co-found and invest in amazing
unicorns
build the best climate tech industry in
the whole world
thanks stanford
maybe publish a book and really go big
but as i began achieving these goals
and i talked to over a hundred companies
in the climate tech space in the past
year
i couldn't help but notice an absence
you see
we are obsessed
with becoming
identifying
the best
players on the field and i think that's
great
but what will make the night and day
difference
for our future
is in fact
influencing and electing
the referees who are going to change the
much needed rules of the game
and i'm telling you those rules have to
be changed in the fight against climate
in order to make the difference between
the future i described and the one that
you want your children to see
i want to say that i too
am a player on the field i've been a
player three times starting at the gsb
and we haven't won a match yet the first
was when i met my classmate stella
on zoom before starting business school
we were stoked by the idea of creating
the platform that will transform carbon
emission tracking for the food supply
space
now we somehow fold some phds to join us
drank way too much coffee and we were
pitching to some of the best vcs on
silicon valley uh sand hill road within
three months
wow i was shocked but so excited
and
said 1vc
love your passion love your idea
but
this is rooted far too heavily in the
policy space political incentives
standard setting
that's not where i put my money i pass
sorry
me in my head
you
pass are you serious
will climate change not affect you too
if you don't fund this solution
who will
this wake up call was extremely humbling
but it taught me two important things
one
of course the investor had a right to
10x returns
that's their job
but more importantly
entrepreneurship and the private sector
alone
is not enough
to get us out
of the climate crisis
changing the rules is paramount and i
want to talk about how
in particular what does it look like
and how does it involve you
i've lived in california for 10 years
one of the most consequential bills that
was passed is senate bill 100 in 2018.
who's going to charge their phone
tonight
okay
looks like everybody
when you plug your phone into that wall
tonight
two-thirds of the power which flows into
your device
is from fossil fuels the other third
from renewables in the state of
california
if sb 100 is met by the 2050s
that two-thirds is phased down to zero
by the time my kid goes to college
why is this important
40
of our emissions come from the power
sector so it's not about how many
electric cars we can produce or make or
afford if that grid is not clean if
those standards are not set if sb 100 is
not passed
it doesn't make a difference
and it's not just about one smart bill
being passed
it was about the assembly member who
bravely put the bill on the floor on
your behalf
lobbied and defended
this bill in all his drafts through two
years of lobbying from over 300 external
forces
that pressure test allowed your voice to
be heard on the floor and the bill was
passed
the impact is huge
because that decision inked in the law
spurred
other states to follow suit and
eventually the national administration
2021 was a watershed year in policy
making
and i'm here to tell you it's no
coincidence that it was also
the historically peak year for venture
funding in the same climate technology
space
so that's how the rules are changed
and that's your role
here is one more dimension
raise your hand in the room if you are
approaching 30
or remember what being 30 feels like
thank you
congratulations
because all of you are the average
lifespan
of a coal fire plant
or an electric grid
you choose now
think about the policy maker who is
sitting in their office figuring out how
to spend their taxpayer money
on this one asset that has to have a
shelf life of 30 years into the future
critical infrastructure that will keep
the lights on
for all of our future children
what a high stakes decision when you
only have one time to make it in this
once in every 30 30-year purchasing
cycle
think about the ways that we can de-risk
that decision by having the right
incentives in place for this particular
policy maker
this is where you and i
all have a role in civic
engagement
the best news is i know that you care
you want to act
and therefore you have the agency and
the ability to create change
on that note i tell you to vote in all
your elected officials who do have a
plan
for changing the rules around
climate change
rules that do not show up in quarterly
earnings cycles or terms sheets
these represent
protection for rural families
who simply need their first megawatt
hour
of electricity
these rules that don't show up in terms
sheets
include protection for entire
communities from cape town and south
africa all the way to west virginia here
in the united states whose livelihoods
are upended
when
other interests force the transition
away from fossil fuels in the next 30
years
when we think about your political
impact
we must go beyond the presidential races
to the state and local in this
conversation
i call you to become leaders who make
those hard choices
and i want to give you three very
concrete ways
to do that as a player on the field or
as a future referee of the game
think about the five people that you
spend the most time with
number one
research shows
that voting is a habitual act
it takes that parent
or that family member and friend to take
a first-timer to the booth
can you take your family to the next
local election
number two
research also shows that loss of social
capital
is the biggest inhibitor
to voices that want to speak out in a
homogenous group in this case
think about the climate skeptic in your
investment team
or think about that voice who wants to
drive change but finds no ally in a
silent room
can you be that ally
or that disruptor
of a social norm
okay and then number three
for those of you sitting here
who want to run for office one day and i
would love to see it
you can engage with a stanford-funded
non-profit called climate cabinet
whose whole job is to
empower you and your staffers
with a knowledgeable
actionable
relevant and constituent-friendly
platform about climate
from how we produce power to how we grow
our food
to how we manufacture
and run our buildings
the possibilities are there
and i can feel it
in all of your hands
so let's come back
to the 2015 i had talked about
actually not the one i had talked about
but the one that we all want our
children to see
what do you want them to see
will it be blue skies
or orange
what is the air
that they smell
when they play soccer
or the water that they taste
at the end of a long day
i know that each of us all have an
important role to play
and from this day forward
we will be judged on the decisions we
make when it mattered
or the decisions we did not
together
we can all
employ civic engagement and our vote
to move the needle forward
for the future that we want to see
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you